den recht hey was geht ab netz bekommen
bahnen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut ich hab ja letztens
irgendwann so ein video gemacht da bin
ich halt losgefahren hab mir so ein paar
macdonald produkte gekauft die halt
wirklich unpopulär sind also wie die
meisten nicht kennen und ich habe euch
in diesem video gefragt hier ist es
übrigens da ist auf jeden fall ganz cool
angekommen wenn da jetzt mal fokussieren
würde was er nicht und ich habe euch in
diesem video gefragt ob ich das gleiche
vielleicht auch mal mit burger king
machen soll und in den kommentaren haben
sehr viele geschrieben dass der auf bock
haben deswegen habe ich mich jetzt mal
ein bisschen informiert und siehst mal
kann ich wirklich sagen also bei merkel
habe ich das sehr gerne produkte testen
die niemand kennt wobei ich da jetzt
sagen muss das natürlich produkte dabei
waren die wirklich fast die man kennt
das ein oder andere sollten aber schon
die einen oder anderen gekannt haben bei
werken habe jetzt allerdings produkt
gefunden
also da wette ich jetzt wirklich dass
die niemand kennen wenn ihr das video
noch nicht gesehen habt verlinkt ich
euch am ende nur wenn man jetzt hier mal
schaut was werken für produkte hat ich
sage mal nur kurz ein begriff und zwar
apfel pommes wirklich apfel pommes es
kann gut sein dass das ziemlich neues
ich habe davon auf jeden fall vorher
noch nie gehört auch vitamine kommen die
nicht in die tüte dann probier mal diese
hier unsere apfel pommes aus frisch
geschnittenen jona gold erfüllen so
leute wir machen das ganze mal zu und
ich würde sagen let's go der ist schon
wieder so dreckig noch etwas wirklich
unfassbar man fährt damit einmal durch
die gegend und der sieht schon wieder
aus wie alter kommt euch das mal an
naja gibt schlimmeres da hinten liegen
noch meine drei neuen adventskalender
das sind wirklich witzige teile glaube
ich dann gibt es auf jeden fall auch
noch ein video zu
ich weiß noch nicht wann jetzt fahren
wir los ich will gar nicht zu viel waren
und wir sehen uns gleich wieder herzlich
willkommen beim barocken ihren
bestellungen bitte
hallo ich habe gerne einmal die backen
schießen
die becken preis
dazu kommt noch smoothie strawberry
banane die apfel pommes haben sie die
haben sie nicht hast du an und hott
blondie haben sie den haben sie auch
nicht ach so ja das war's dann erstmal
ja also hier muss ich erst mal sagen ich
finde ich eine frechheit wenn es auf der
internetseite steht dann erwartet man ja
auch dass man es bekommt das waren
eigentlich die produkte die ich
unbedingt haben wollte und genau das
gibt es jetzt nicht also leute ich gebe
natürlich nicht auf ich wollte euch nur
kurz mal als zwischenergebnis das hier
zeigen guckt euch mal wie das aussieht
von oben da freue ich mich schon
[Musik]
auf jeden fall leute ich habe dazu ja
auch schon mal wie ich bin jetzt schon
fast eine stunde unterwegs ne ich hab so
was ja schon mal ein video gemacht weil
mir das auch mal passiert dass das zwei
also komplett um gefahren sind könnt ihr
euch mal anschauen wenn ihr wollt ansage
an
ich könnte mir die musik ausmachen
ansage an porsche oder so oder an den
porsche fahrer keine ahnung auf jeden
fall sind gerade ziemlich komisch
gefahren so ich habe jetzt alles wir
fahren jetzt nach hause und dann wird
probiert
also wir sehen uns gleich also es gleich
so etwas geht
ich habe es jetzt wirklich nach
eineinhalb stunden mal geschafft mich
hierhin zu setzen
die kamera war noch kaputt und das ist
jetzt wahrscheinlich schon okay lauwarm
ist es noch leute ich nehme das ganze
gerät auch mit einer anderen kamera auf
die nochmal deut besser ist als die mit
der ich das eigentlich auch nicht mehr
aber ich glaube das interessiert euch so
ungefähr gar nicht aber es ist wirklich
kaum zu glauben ich bin noch auf die
autobahn gefahren und bin zu dem pärchen
gefahren dass an der autobahn lage auf
120 kilometer weg war ist was hast du
noch schnellste ich hab so zu der
mitarbeiterin dann gesagt ja ich hätte
gern apfelbaum ist lass mich raten ich
habe keine abgekommen ist und die dann
so doch wir haben abgepasst und nicht so
harry glawe pommes alex wie eine stunde
unterwegs auf der suche nach apfel
pommes netterweise habe ich übrigens von
den bürgerkriegen wo ich als erstes war
weil so viele sachen ich hatte nicht
eigentlich haben wollte ein vanille
sheikh in xxl geschenkt bekommen
dankeschön
deswegen würde ich sagen können wir
damit auch an
[Musik]
schmeckt wirklich gut zu entwickeln
haben wir denn ich habe einen hot braun
bestellt mit sahne
ich habe vielleicht schon gründe mich
auf zu reden
wir fangen erst mal damit an hier haben
wir die bacon cheese nuggets habe ich
vorher noch nie was von gehört also ohne
spaß kießling es ist geil bacon
schieflage steht nun gibts hass und
gleichzeitig dazu auf die welt
was geht alter bacon jazzpreis karl die
kommission nicht ganz durch aber schon
das gut
und hier haben wir die blackies frei
passend zu den welten gomez bin ich auch
mal gespannt
diese soße ich weiß nicht welche das ist
aber die ist sogar teil so ich muss
erstmal auch irgendwann will ich muss
jetzt aber wirklich sagen das ist echt
lecker also hätte ich gar nicht mal
gedacht sind nämlich eigentlich gar
nicht so der bacon verhältnis generell
30 erreicht nur noch sehr wenig fleisch
aber schmeckt gut so jetzt haben wir
hier den strawberry banana steht das
vielleicht drauf wahrscheinlich nicht
nein das hat jetzt mal eben recht
unappetitlich aus aber er ist jetzt
leicht geschmolzen
ihr könnt ja geil mega gut der ich nicht
so gut aber schmeckt richtig gut ihr
könnt ja meine kommentare schreiben ob
ihr den schon mal probiert habt oder
schreibt mir noch mal bis in die
kommentare von welcher seite er wusste
dass die wirklich existiert also ich
hier ungelogen von keiner so läuft dann
kommen wir jetzt endlich zu den april
pommes dies glaube ich nirgendwo anders
auf der welt gibt ich mein appell puls
wer bietet apfel kurs an die sind auf
der karte oder im internet so aus und in
echt sehen sie ich meine die verpackung
ist jetzt nicht so wichtig aber was ist
das naja das ist nicht gut
also leute jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wie eine apfel pommes schmeckt
wahrscheinlich nach apfel
[Applaus]
ich könnte jetzt auch zu meinem nachbarn
gehen dann ein apfel vom baum pflücken
der schon längst gepflückt werden hätte
sollen weil der schon längst zu alt ist
versteht ihr was ich meine
da rein weißen und ich glaube das wird
genauso schmecken also ab willkommen ist
ist jetzt nicht so dass schütz naja
leute sieht halt echt nicht so
appetitlich aus und zwar wollte ich den
hot blondie haben dann habe ich auch
wirklich noch nie irgendwo gesehen habe
allerdings nur den hot brownie bekommen
den habe ich aber auch noch nie wirklich
so leid gesehen und habe auch gar keine
armen wieder schmecken soll ich habe
allerdings nur den heute frau nie
bekommen weil es den anderen echten
nirgendwo gab
sorry mir aber ich kann das nicht erst
da ist erinnert mich zu sehr an gegen
etwas anderes für mich frage mich warum
verkauft man das so kann nehmt doch
wenigstens sagen die sich auch irgendwie
darauf hält oder na ja heute also das
schmeckt echt alles ziemlich gut
außerdem braun ideen habe ich jetzt
nicht probiert und ob jetzt ein apfel
aus dem garten von eurem nachbarn ist
oder die apfelbäume ist dann auch egal
schafft dass die dadurch gefallen dass
auf jeden fall noch nach oben da wir
sehen uns morgen wieder am morgen 19 uhr
gibt's neues cooles video die heute 36